this year alyssa henry made it onto
the america's richest self-made women's
list
alyssa henry is ranked 57th on the list
this year with a net worth of 555
million and it comes from her work at
square
the payments company which has just
been taking off on the stock market
since
2020.
alyssa is the seller lead seller is one
of the two
main branches of square
and it's the one that
i think most people associate with
square because uh
it's like basically in charge of their
little white reader and
all the other like ways that you would
pay for something
at a store
uh you know a lot of brick and mortar
shops have like a little square reader
now
she's been leading that unit since 2014
and
she's really grown it out from
what was basically just like a
hardware thing at the time out into this
like
full software suite with all kinds of
different features beyond just payments
itself
you know payroll rewards
loyalty stuff
all these different features all baked
into the software she owns a
0.3 stake in the company which seems
kind of small but that actually amounts
to
555 million dollars she started out at
microsoft like two decades ago and then
really continued to like keep on working
her way up the chain there and then she
moved over to amazon and then it was
kind of a similar thing where over the
course of seven years she worked her way
up to a vice president position she
helped out uh
turning
the company's software from what's
called like a monolithic architecture to
microservices architecture and that
basically means that like
before amazon was one giant chunk of
software or all the different parts of
amazon like amazon shopping versus like
amazon streaming
it was all like baked into one piece of
software
so that made the software really clunky
over time as you know amazon got bigger
and bigger it looks like square is um
[Music]
just going to be one of the big players
in the whole
financial sector for the long haul i
talked to one analyst who said that
buying square stock in 2021 is like
buying jp morgan stock in
there have been talks about you know her
potentially being
one of the candidates to succeed jack
dorsey as ceo if he ever steps down
but you know it's hard to say if he's
ever going to step down it doesn't
really seem like he is
the year that she joined square the
company's revenue was
about like 850 million dollars
and now it's
more than ten times that it's like nine
and a half billion dollars now
and
i would say that
her role as the seller lead has been
probably the biggest driver of that
growth for square
because seller is you know square's
biggest branch it's the one that
they've
they're you know known for and it's the
one that
that was the original um
business model of the company so
she's really grown that out and now
square has kind of diversified you know
they're
they're also
the company behind cash app and you know
they bought title the music service
and you know behind jack they're really
getting into bitcoin but
you know like the seller component is
you know the original business of the
company and i think it's going to
continue to be
you know one of the key pillars of
square moving forward
you